le bruit de grenouilles qui coassent a
remplacé celui des applaudissements en
temps normal sur cette scène vikings et
drakkar en feu font face à trois mille
spectateurs mais confinement oblige le
puy du fou n'a pas pu entamer sa saison
2020 comme prévu pour autant les vikings
sont toujours sur le pied de guerre
pierre est l'un des cavaliers du
spectacle pas de représentation au
programme mais un entraînement pour ses
montures où on continuer l'entretien des
chevaux on continue à les entretenir
musculairement
on continue le travail tous quel drapeau
tout ce qui est un peu spectacle bon on
se prépare à tout le monde à repartir en
spectacle la semaine prochaine grève
on reprend les répétitions donc en tout
cas nous on est prêts on fait juste de
l'entretien quoi en attendant ce jour
salvateur tout le monde est sur le pont
pour travailler sur les futures mesures
de sécurité et rien n'échappe à l'oeil
de freddy voulez qu'on fasse un petit
point ensemble sur les différents
modules en plexiglas que les menuisiers
ont construit pour les boutiques du
bourg 1900 donc la deuxième étape
maintenant étant donné qu'ils sont tous
assemblés sais que tu arrives à les
intégrer au maximum dans chaque boutique
tous nos talents en fait ce qui sont
présents sur le parc vont pouvoir en
fait être protégé par ses parois en
plexiglas qui permettent justement
d'accueillir le visiteur dans les
meilleures conditions mais aussi de
protéger nos talents le savoir-faire de
marie ici après ce sera en fait
d'intégrer au maximum esthétiquement
chaque module en plexi dedans les
espaces de vente aujourd'hui
aucune date n'a été fixée pour la
réouverture des parcs et m pour nicolas
de villiers c'est l'incompréhension que
nous avons du mal à comprendre c'est que
les plages puisse rouvrir ce qui est une
bonne chose
alors que ce sont des espaces qui ne
sont pas organisés par une justement une
pensée une équipe d'organisation
quand nous ici au puy du fou nous sommes
des spécialistes de l'organisation comme
l'ensemble des parcs d'ailleurs et nous
savons organiser les flux de personnes
la désinfection des lieux traversés par
le public la distribution du gel
hydroalcoolique toutes les mesures
nécessaires à la distribution par
exemple de nourriture et de paniers
repas qui soit adaptée à la situation
ce que ne sait pas faire par exemple une
ruelle du mont saint michel ou même une
ruelle paris
sienne actuellement ouverte au public
ce que nous demandons c'est pouvoir
ouvrir le 2 juin et surtout être prévenu
de cette possibilité à avoir le feu vert
du gouvernement suffisamment tôt pour
que nous puissions nous organiser le puy
du fou ces trois semaines de logistique
avant l'ouverture
trois semaines de préparation de
formation de répétition de nos
spectacles par exemple pour demander la
réouverture du puy du fou une pétition
en ligne a été lancé une pétition à
l'initiative de la maire des herbiers
une commune qui jouit des répercussions
économiques du parc le puy du fou ces
quatre mille 700 emplois intermédiaires
créés dans la région et 500 millions
d'euros de répercussions économiques par
an
[Musique]